we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
this is a very important voicemail this
is a voicemail from a trump-supporting
cuban-american
and i want to take this seriously okay
listen to what this gentleman says and
then we're going to talk about it
hello mr pacman my name is juan i'm a
cuban-american
and i voted for trump
the reason i'm calling is
to ask the following question and this
might
help ease the concerns some of us have
what are democrats
doing to ensure or
put at these concerns of this country
steering towards communism or socialism
[Music]
like what unfortunately happened to cuba
and other countries if
democrats are able to
[Music]
show some type of effort
or talk about
ways that they are trying to prevent
that from happening maybe that will
uh help gain more votes from those
concerned like i am
so this is really important because the
framing of the question is completely
wrong
okay this gentleman says i'm a
cuban-american and i voted for trump and
on my spanish language show we've been
talking a lot about this
what what exactly is going on what could
be done
to for democrats to better appeal to
cuban-american voters who often
reflexively out of anti-castro bias are
quick to fall for claims
that any old democrat is a socialist or
a communist when they are not the
question is the wrong one because the
question is
what what what have democrats done what
can democrats do to convince us
that they are not really going to become
make the country socialist or communist
joe biden is not a socialist or a
communist
joe biden has not proposed a single
communist or socialist policy
there are no actual socialists or
communists
in positions of power in the democratic
party in the united states
aoc has called herself a democratic
socialist and so has bernie
and they are not not only are they a
small sliver of the democratic party
they really are social democrats they're
not advocating
uh for the socialization of the means of
production they are certainly not
communist so
the problem is not that joe biden hasn't
yet convinced us enough that he's not a
socialist
there's no evidence there's no policy
there's no reason to think the current
democratic party
has any interest in making the united
states a socialist country
the problem is too many people have been
brainwashed to think that that's the
case
absent any evidence whatsoever
and so we need to deal with this at a
systemic level
is it possible that if we better
understood
socialism and communism people wouldn't
fall for
barack obama as a socialist joe biden's
a socialist
is part of it an education thing uh it
is part of it
irresponsible republican campaigns that
if you tell a lie enough times it starts
to become the truth
i don't know the answer but when you
hear that the question is so wrong
what what what what should democrats do
to convince us they're not socialists
what have they done to make you think
they are not a single
sexual socialist policy it's stunning
and it's sad and listen
i am not a socialist i am not a
communist i have never
been in favor of the cuban nor
venezuelan regimes
try out of my own self-interest i would
be telling you
if joe biden was trying to turn the
united states
into a cuban or venezuelan socialist
situation because i would be against
that
i wouldn't vote for that so uh
out of my own views i would be coming to
you and saying guys
there's a risk of socialism here there
is no such risk
and that's where this has gone wrong and
you end up with folks saying
i don't know that biden has done enough
to uh
show me that he's not a socialist has he
done anything to suggest he is
and the answer is of course no we have a
great bonus show for you today we're
going to talk about another retail chain
filing for bankruptcy
we're going to talk about a very
interesting first amendment ruling
involving voice of america
and you are not going to believe what is
going on
with the my pillow guy and
the kenosha shooter kyle rittenhouse all
of those stories
and more on today's bonus show get
instant access
by becoming a member at joinpakman.com